Social media is flipping out over the Spanish
sci-fi/horror flick The Platform, which secured
its stateside release through Netflix.
The film is being called a perfect parable
for our troubled times, not to mention a taut,
unblinking, merciless thriller.
In recent times, Netflix has been regularly
shouldering its way into the national spotlight
with the kind of original content that seems
specifically calibrated to grab the eyeballs
of millions of people all at once.
First, on February 13th, there was Love is
Blind, an unapologetically melodramatic reality
series focused on a batch of couples who date,
court, and make the decision as to whether
or not to get married without ever actually,
you know, seeing each other.
Then, on March 20th, there was Tiger King,
an original docu-series focused on private
zoo owner Joe Exotic and a cast of insane
caricatures, all of whom are, improbably,
real people.
"When Joe rented that helicopter, it gave
him a lot of really bad ideas."
Now, there's The Platform, which as of the
making of this video has earned an 82% Fresh
rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
The show has viewers in disbelief over how
ridiculously timely it is - not to mention
well-crafted, well-acted, and relentlessly
disturbing.
American audiences aren't likely to recognize
much of the cast, but that will only lend
even more gritty authenticity to the proceedings.
So, what is The Platform all about, anyway?
The movie centers on Goreng, a resident of
the Pit, which is a prison constructed like
a tower of indeterminate height.
Each level has massive holes in its floor
and ceiling, through which the titular platform
descends every day.
On this platform is enough food for all of
the Pit's prisoners - but the inmates near
the top are free to take as much food as they
want, often not leaving enough - or any at
all - for those on the lower levels.
Throughout the film, Goreng finds himself
assigned to different levels of the Pit, sharing
space with some unsettling roommates.
Also figuring heavily into the movie's increasingly
alarming narrative: a mysterious woman who
rides the platform, searching the Pit's various
levels for her child.
Of course, Goreng is eventually confronted
with violence, cannibalism, and other unspeakable
situations - all while trying to figure out
just how far down the levels go, and attempting
to get the prisoners to cooperate rather than
working against each other.
The film sports a bizarre final reveal that
will leave you scratching your head - and
wondering just what kind of message we should
be sending to those on the top levels of our
own (metaphorical) Pit.
It's easy to view The Platform as an allegory
for class warfare, an issue which has gained
more and more political prominence over the
course of the last decade or so.
On its surface, it can also be seen as a simple,
stark message: Things could be a whole lot
worse!
This seemed to be the takeaway for several
Twitterers, including user @HansGr00ber, who
wrote with tongue planted firmly in cheek,
"If you want to watch a grim film about being
confined in a nightmare prison without food
I suggest watching The Platform on Netflix.
It's pretty good."
User @katevaldez was a little more succinct,
writing,
"Crazy s---.
Food will never be the same again."
User @kathdeclaw posted a strong recommendation,
along with an equally strong warning.
"Just finished watching [The Platform on]
Netflix and I'm wrecked and...I need to lie
down.
You know it's a good one when it's that impactful.
It was extreme and hard to watch but has a
relevant message apt in these desperate times.
12/10 highly recommended."
User @steph_bonchi echoed the sentiment.
"I can't believe The Platform was only 1hr
35 minutes.
It felt like 2 - 3 hours simply because of
how heavy, gruesome, irky and painful it is
to watch.
It was torture and I couldn't blink for fear
that I would miss a second."
The Platform is strong stuff, indeed - but
for fans of jolting horror, it should be a
welcome escape.
A gory, nerve-wrenching, really messed-up
escape.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror flicks are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.